before Putin's speech world leaders
meeting at the United Nations denounced
Russia's war in Ukraine President Biden
speaks to the U.N General Assembly later
this morning Chief Foreign Affairs
correspondent and host to Face the
Nation Margaret Brennan joins us right
now good morning so what do you make of
this address by President Putin oh this
is a message not just to the Russian
people but right here in New York to
President Biden to president zielinski
and ahead of this release U.S officials
were briefing and called it crass a
crass move to go ahead and do something
like this they are challenging Vladimir
Putin is challenging the very basis of
the UN which was supposed to be might
doesn't make right he's saying let me
show you because I'm not backing down
and I'm not pulling out and he's
dangling this nuclear threat again as of
this morning the latest intelligence is
that nuclear weapons are not being moved
there's no indication of that at this
point but the use of catastrophic
weapons like nukes has been a consistent
concern and you heard President Biden
speak about that just as recently as
this weekend on 60 Minutes so we have
President Putin challenging the U.N
meanwhile U.N leaders are Gathering can
anything come out of that assembly
meeting that's going to affect the war
in Ukraine well the UN is the world's
Parliament right I mean you have
countries there who uh are affected
directly by the food crisis I'm thinking
the entire continent of Africa I'm
thinking about South America and
President Biden is going to try to rally
them to say don't blame us look at who
is stopping uh grain shipments and look
at why your food costs are skyrocketing
and speak to the global South as it's
called to try to isolate Russia more
because there is resentment that this
just looks like it's the West trying to
dictate to the rest of the world how to
behave here and you know not everyone
actually wants to be a democracy so when
Vladimir Putin says hey don't criticize
me on human rights there are some
willing people and countries to go along
with that so President Biden's going to
try to flip that script a little bit in
his speech today and continue to try to
keep not just the west but the world
isolating Russia but it's a big
challenge yeah Putin definitely putting
the world on notice very good to have
you here
even fear for the United Nations but you
get to weigh in on Putin as well always
good to see you Margaret Brennan good to
talk with you